[Música]
y
el consejo de seguridad de la onu emitió
una resolución en la que respalda los
esfuerzos de paz en ucrania que ha hecho
el secretario general antonio guterres
el organismo lidera la evacuación de
civiles en la acería de as hostales
mariupol hoy evacuaron a 50 personas
tras la explosión del hotel saratoga en
cuba las autoridades se concentran en
investigar las causas del accidente el
presidente miguel díaz canel descartó
que se tratara de un ataque al menos 10
personas fallecieron
el presidente mexicano andrés manuel
lópez obrador continúa su gira
internacional este viernes viajó a el
salvador y seguirá en honduras al igual
que ocurrió en guatemala el tema central
del encuentro del mandatario con sus
homólogos es la migración conectaremos
con tegucigalpa
bienvenidos a las noticias de france 24
y los saluda maría que hará calle y
comenzamos con noticias de la guerra por
primera vez desde que inició el
conflicto el consejo de seguridad de la
onu adoptó por unanimidad una
declaración sobre ucrania los 15 países
miembros incluidos rusia respaldaron la
resolución en la que expresan un fuerte
apoyo a los esfuerzos que ha hecho el
secretario general antonio guterres para
encontrar una solución pacífica sin
embargo en el documento no se mencionan
palabras como guerra invasión u
operación militar especial esto para
evitar que moscú vetará la decisión como
ya ha hecho antes uno de los intentos de
la onu es la evacuación en la
siderúrgica de us of talent mariupol hoy
salieron 50 civiles incluidos niños
veamos
en mariupol el alto el fuego decretado
por los rusos no se cumplió el batallón
de azov denuncia sangrientos
enfrentamientos y acusó a moscú de
atacar a los civiles pero a pesar de los
combates el viernes se inició una nueva
evacuación de al menos 23 civiles
hoy ha continuado la operación de
rescate de mariupol con la ayuda de la
onu y el comité internacional de la cruz
roja la gente está de camino a una zona
segura en total más de 150 personas de
asof tal y más de 300 personas de
mariupol y sus suburbios han sido
evacuadas a través del corredor
humanitario esta semana convenio tarde
un corredor el presidente ucraniano
también acusa a los rusos de seguir
bombardeando la zona mientras que el
kremlin lo niega
nuestro presidente y comandante supremo
el presidente putin ha dado públicamente
la orden de no lanzar un asalto a la
planta de la substancia no se ha dado
ninguna otra orden
el jueves por la noche vladimir putin
dijo que el ejército ruso seguía
preparado para garantizar la evacuación
de los civiles al parecer todavía hay
200 refugiados en el complejo atrapados
entre los combates ucranianos tras más
de dos meses de asedio e intensos
bombardeos mariupol está casi
completamente destruida el presidente
volodymyr selenski dijo que sería
necesaria una versión moderna del plan
marshall para reconstruir la ciudad así
como todas las demás devastadas por la
guerra como consecuencia de esta guerra
muchas gasolineras se han quedado sin
combustible debido a la explosión de
refinerías y la imposibilidad de
importarlo una situación que algunos
ucranianos aseguran que es peor que lo
que se vivió en el país tras la caída de
la unión soviética nuestra enviada
especial a ucrania catalina gómez ángel
estuvo en una gasolinera cerca de la
localidad de klamath orsc en la región
del donbass allí pudo hablar con algunas
personas que hacían fila para
abastecerse de gasolina
filas como estas de decenas de vehículos
frente a las estaciones de servicio son
una imagen común actualmente en ucrania
muchas de estas estaciones no tienen
gasolina estamos en una que está en la
entrada del donbass cerca de la ciudad
de cromatos sin miel en esta región del
país la situación es peor por diferentes
motivos esta es una región que está en
guerra desde 2014 la situación económica
es muchísimo peor aquí nos cuenta la
población que su vida se ha trastocado
en las últimas semanas especialmente
desde hace dos semanas cuando no tienen
gasolina ellos dicen que además esto ha
hecho que los el precio de los alimentos
se incremente y su gran temor es que el
precio de la gasolina sin regresa es que
sea muchísimo mayor
y es
más
esto nos ha impactado de muy mala manera
porque nuestro trabajo como conductor
depende de la gasolina cuando el precio
de la gasolina sube ganamos menos cuando
ganamos menos dinero es más difícil para
nosotros sobrevivir los precios del
mercado y de los han aumentado algunos
de los almacenes han tenido que cerrar
entre el 50 o el 60 por ciento de la
ciudad se ha ido el resto de los que nos
quedamos sobreviven
pastel medicatura de hostales y
yuri también nos contaba que este es el
momento más difícil de su vida que
incluso después de la caída de la unión
soviética cuando este país sufrió
grandes consecuencias económicas no lo
pasó tan mal y es que la explosión de
varias refinerías en ucrania y la
incapacidad para importar gasolina ha
creado esa sensación dentro de la
población de inestabilidad y de
inseguridad no solamente a nivel
alimentario los precios de los alimentos
son mucho mayor lo que crea pues más
angustia dentro de la población ya
sufriendo problemas económicos como
consecuencia de la guerra sino también
en seguridad especialmente en regiones
como ésta donde la mayor tranquilidad de
las personas viene de tener gasolina en
el carro para poder huir en el momento
que pase algo
hungría rechazó la propuesta de la
comisión europea de embargar las
importaciones de petróleo ruso el primer
ministro viktor orbán señaló que frenar
esas compras equivaldría a una bomba
atómica para la economía húngara según
sus cálculos el país necesitaría al
menos cinco años para dejar de depender
del petróleo ruso los detalles en el
siguiente informe
es un paso demasiado lejos para viktor
orbán el viernes el primer ministro
húngaro rechazó el último proyecto de
sanciones a las exportaciones de
petróleo ruso anunciado por la unión
europea newton estábamos dispuestos a
decir que si a los primeros cinco
paquetes de sanciones pero desde la
primera oportunidad dejamos claro que
habrá una línea roja de no ir tan lejos
y que no podamos estar de acuerdo con
ellos esto se trata de un embargo
energético
esta propuesta es como una bomba nuclear
lanzada sobre la economía húngara
los funcionarios de la unión europea
habían previsto una excepción para
hungría y eslovaquia dos países
dependientes del gas ruso y que podrían
haber continuado con su compra de
petróleo ruso hasta finales del 2023
pero orbán afirma que necesitan más
tiempo
y puntos sabemos exactamente lo que
necesitamos necesitamos cinco años para
completar todo el proceso no llegaremos
a ninguna parte con una exención de un
año y medio
un rechazo que fue inmediatamente
criticado por ucrania
petersen y can't be in europe google en
youtube por si algún país de europa
sigue oponiéndose a un embargo del
petróleo ruso observación sin embargo
con ryan webb
habrá buenas razones para decir que ese
país es cómplice de los crímenes
cometidos por rusia en territorio
ucraniano
barbassa in the tree of y break las
sanciones de la unión europea contra
rusia no pueden entrar en vigor sin el
acuerdo de los 27 estados miembros
el presidente de eeuu joe biden firmó un
nuevo paquete de 150 millones de dólares
para enviar misiles municiones radares y
otros equipos a ucrania la casa blanca
puede retirar armas y material de las
fuerzas militares estadounidenses para
darlo a otras naciones y es de allí que
vendrán esos recursos desde que empezó
la guerra en ucrania de eeuu le ha dado
armamento a kiev por un valor de 3.400
millones de dólares adicionalmente el
congreso estadounidense estudio un
proyecto que si es aprobado le daría
asistencia por más de 33 mil millones de
dólares a los ucranianos
y en otras noticias el ministerio de la
construcción de cuba evalúa el estado en
el que quedó el hotel saratoga luego de
la explosión de esta mañana las
autoridades determinarán si es posible
rescatar el edificio construido en 1880
o si deberán demoler lo el estallido
dejó al menos 18 muertos y 64 heridos
según el más reciente reporte de la
presidencia el hotel saratoga es uno de
los más famosos de la isla con cinco
estrellas y ubicado en el paseo del
prado- una de las principales avenidas
de la habana vieja investigaciones
preliminares apuntan a un posible escape
de gas como la causa de la explosión y
el presidente miguel díaz canel sostiene
que no fue una bomba ni un atentado sino
un accidente
visitando los lugares todo parece ser un
incidente un accidente como
una explosión y por lo tanto también un
derrumbe un año atrás
y hay un grupo de personas que están
recibiendo
auxilios equipos de rescate como el
rápido contacto del convenio de toda la
fuerza
especializada tenemos personas
fallecidas lamentablemente y en
centroamérica una de las noticias es la
reunión del presidente de el salvador
nazismo que le con su homólogo mexicano
andrés manuel lópez obrador este último
llegó este viernes a san salvador
después de haber estado en guatemala y
seguirá su gira internacional en
honduras y en cuba el tema central de
todos los encuentros es la migración
conectamos a esta hora con tegucigalpa
donde está nuestra corresponsal que ni a
torres que ni a bienvenida el presidente
mexicano habló de financiar en el
salvador el programa sembrando vida para
intentar disminuir la migración ese fue
el mismo programa que está respaldando
en guatemala cuéntenos en qué consiste y
que otros temas habló con su homólogo
salvadoreño nadie y mujer
graciasmaria clara antes decirte que nos
encontramos en este momento en la casa
de gobierno de honduras donde en unos
instantes arribará el presidente
mexicano andrés lópez obrador como bien
lo decía estuvo hace unas horas en el
salvador donde anunció más
financiamiento para estos dos programas
primero es sembrando vida que está
desarrollado en el salvador desde el
2019 y consiste en apoyar a más de 10
mil agricultores en el tema de siembra
de hortalizas
por otro lado fortalecerá también el
programa 'jóvenes construyendo futuro se
inyectará dinero a estos programas para
evitar precisamente la migración de
salvadoreños en este caso hacia los eeuu
pero como bien lo decía marx y aclara el
tema central de estas reuniones del
presidente mexicano con sus homólogos
del triángulo del norte que son
guatemala el salvador y honduras
precisamente el tema más importante es
la migración aquí en honduras se
focalizará también en la lucha contra el
narcotráfico y cuéntenos brevemente que
se espera que ocurre en el encuentro
entre andrés manuel lópez obrador y la
presidenta de honduras xiomara castró
hay muchísima expectativa con la llegada
del presidente mexicano ya que este país
es del norte de américa siempre ha sido
un aliado estratégico de honduras y ha
apoyado a este países centroamericanos
en las diferentes catástrofes naturales
y en este sentido pues espera que estos
mismos programas se desarrollarán en
guatemala y que sigue apoyando en el
salvador queden cimentados también en
este país pero como decía el tema
central en la agenda con la presidenta
xiomara castró es precisamente el tema
migratorio ya que honduras es justamente
el país que más asilo y refugio pide en
méxico una vez que estas caravanas de
migrantes cruzan guatemala llegan al
país azteca con el propósito de
finalmente avanzar hacia los eeuu
gracias por este reporte de estaremos
atentos y cambiamos de noticia porque
sri lanka no hubo una nueva huelga
nacional en la que miles de personas
protestaron contra las políticas del
gobierno de gotabhaya rajapakse a la
administración declaró
de emergencia para intentar contener las
manifestaciones el descontento social es
causado por la peor crisis económica que
ha enfrentado el país con una inflación
superior al 18 por ciento y con los
alimentos y los combustibles cada vez
más escasos por eso piden la renuncia
del presidente les contamos en este
reporte
se reunieron frente al parlamento de sri
lanka para expresar su ira desde el
jueves miles de estudiantes han
bloqueado el acceso al edificio exigen
la dimisión del presidente gota valla
raya pesca y de su hermano el primer
ministro
en lugar de irse a casa lo que ha hecho
el gobierno es cambiar la composición de
su parlamento para salvaguardar su poder
y
la policía utilizó cañones de agua y
gases lacrimógenos para dispersar a los
manifestantes sin éxito miles de
ciudadanos de sri lanka salieron a la
calle el viernes para protestar contra
las políticas del gobierno una huelga
nacional con un fuerte seguimiento con
el transporte prácticamente paralizado y
muchas tiendas cerradas pero también
fábricas bancos e incluso edificios
gubernamentales
y
exigimos que tras la huelga de hoy el
gobierno se desentienda de todas sus
responsabilidades y permita que el país
vuelva a avanzar por un nuevo camino
tensiones políticas causadas por la peor
crisis económica y financiera de sri
lanka en décadas golpeado por la
pandemia el aumento de los precios del
petróleo y los recortes fiscales del
gobierno el país está al borde de la
quiebra sri lanka ha dejado de pagar su
deuda externa de 51 mil millones de
dólares y solo tiene 50 millones de
dólares en reservas extranjeras desde
hace meses los habitantes tailandeses se
enfrentan a una grave escasez y la
inflación superó el 18 por ciento en
marzo
lo que ganamos no es suficiente para la
comida y mucho menos para otros gastos
solo podemos comer una vez al día a
pesar de las protestas del presidente
rajapaksa se mantiene en el poder el
viernes declaró el estado de emergencia
sigan con france24 para más información
[Música]